these were principles that the
revolutionaries
discovered and developed so for me
the key year is 1765.
and 1765 is the year in which the stamp
act was passed
and that's the moment when everything in
america changes
so i want to back up to those
self-evident truths because it's one of
the topics that i'm actually most
interested in right now and i write a
little bit about
in my book that that there has to be
something outside of
us to organize a society
do you know how much sort of internal
arguing they had as to what those
self-evident truths were
actually and how they all arrived at
what they were
yeah that's a great question so i would
say
that the principal division amongst
colonial americans
in the 1760s and in the 1770s was
between
american patriots and the so-called
loyalists or american tories
that's the great division and and in the
end
they had really very different
conceptions
of what america ought to be and they had
very different conceptions
of the underlying moral principles of
the united states
but once the declaration of independence
was passed
that disagreement became moot
and i think what's most important and
the story that i try to tell
in my book is the story of how
and why american patriots came to
search for discover
and develop the principles that would
ultimately be
elucidated in the declaration of
independence and so
you know going back to your first
question and the twofold purpose of my
book
so on the one hand yes the book is about
the declaration of independence
um it's a close textual analysis of the
declaration
uh particularly of the four self-evident
truths but the book actually in the end
dave is about a lot more than just
the declaration of independence it's
about the american mind
and it's about the deepest causes and
meaning
of the american revolution so as i said
the declaration is a summing up of those
principles but the real question
the really fascinating part of the story
is how the americans
came to those principles because they
didn't hold them necessarily
in say 1760. right these were principles
and let's take um let's take any one of
of the four self-evident truths equality
rights consent and revolution
these were principles that the
revolutionaries discovered
and developed so for me the key year
is 1765. and 1765 is the year in which
the stamp act was passed
and that's the moment when everything in
america changes now the second
quotation uh that really drives my
interpretation of the revolution as a
whole in addition to the one by thomas
jefferson
describing the declaration of
independence is one
by john adams and john adams late in
life
in trying to describe to a friend
what the causes of the revolution were
he he says that the causes that the
revolution was not
the war for independence the true
american revolution he says
was put into effect in the 15 years
before a shot was ever fired at concord
and lexington and the revolution the
true american revolution
he says was a moral revolution
in the minds of the people so
that's what my book is really about the
moral revolution
that occurred in the minds of the
american people and adams's
statement is supported by thomas paine
who at that time also in describing
the causes and meaning of the american
revolution
said that because of the american
revolution
the american people he said hear with
new
ears see with new eyes and think
new thoughts and the new thoughts he
said
had to do with the doctrine of
individual rights
it's the discovery of the doctrine of
natural rights
by the americans that really is the most
important i think revolutionary moment
and so what
what my book then does is it takes each
one of the four self-evident truths
equality rights consent and revolution
and it gives a kind of intellectual
history over
i i devote two chapters to each of the
four
self-evident truths and i trace a kind
of intellectual history
of let's say the idea of equality or
rights
from the late 17th century from the
english philosopher john locke
up through the early 18th century but
then really i spend most of the time in
the book
discussing how the americans developed
these ideas during the 1760s and during
the 1770s
and that's really how the book is is
framed
and that's that's really the story that
it's telling how the americans
discovered these principles so i want so
we did
equality i want to do i want to hit on
the other three more
um but first as they were
debating these things you know one of
the things that i talk about all the
time is they were saying there are
truths outside of us
and then they're saying these are
god-given rights and then also we're
separating church and state
that concept is is pretty profound uh
at least in our modern times that that
men could do
something like that um were they all
sort of on board that was there
was there any pushback that we we can't
well i guess well it's church and state
certainly there was pushback but that we
can't say that there are truths outside
of us
it will lead to anarchy or something
like that
well i think it's true to say that every
single
american revolution believed in the idea
as i said earlier of truth of absolute
objective certain permanent universal
truths but the question is what is the
source
of those truths right that's the really
that's the key question i can also tell
you that
virtually every single american founding
father
believed that for instance the concept
of rights
was grounded in nature and by nature
i mean nature out there right you look
out into the world
uh and you see nature and one of the
really important things
that the founding fathers did was they
adapted
the the ideas of um
17th century english scientists and
philosophers like francis bacon and his
novum organum
and sir isaac newton in his principia
mathematica and john locke and his essay
concerning human understanding
and they they they took the
enlightenment's ideas
of the laws of nature the scientific
laws of nature and they attempted that
to apply them
to man right and they asked the question
are there
moral laws of nature
which means laws that are absolute
permanent and universal
right that you can look out into the
world and you can identify and so and
in order to discover those moral laws
and rights of nature then you have to
study
human nature and so all of america's
founding fathers
were students of the enlightenment they
believed
that there were moral laws and rights of
nature
that could be discovered by examining
human nature
the the more difficult question and
where you do see some division
is i think it's true to say that most of
the founding fathers
were practicing christians and so
therefore they believed
that the laws and rights of nature were
grounded
in an ultimate source then that ultimate
source of course was the supreme being
as he's called in the declaration of
independence now but it's also the case
that not all of the revolutionary
founders uh
were practicing christians um and so
they
they discovered the laws and rights of
nature
in nature and they just they didn't go
the next step but the most important
thing to remember
is that they all believed in the moral
laws and rights of nature
and nature is the key term there if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about academia
instead of non-stop
yelling check out our academia playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell